the vulnerability of going through the
evolution of where you're at politically
and philosophically that's not easy to
do because in a way we have to publicly
put ourselves out there to either say I
was wrong about that belief at one point
of my life or to say listen I'm still of
the same belief you've changed and just
to affiliate myself with you I can't do
that anymore because this is ridiculous
and it's you've cornered me you're
putting me in a bad place but this is
what I'm going to be doing moving
forward what's the Journey of you
evolving with your personal philosophies
whether it's foreign as a military
person of course that's something you
have a lot of experience in economically
as you advance in life and you're saying
okay I'm noticing some of these policies
don't make sense yeah socially you're
seeing what's going on with trans
dilemma venue all these things that
you're being forced to kind of have to
agree with this what's that evolution
been for you politically
look I I think ultimately at its heart
it is about
um
being willing to learn I mean really
it's that simple you know the the the
mindset and world view and what I knew
when I enlisted you know when I enlisted
after uh because of 9 11 like so many
people and then going and deploying into
Iraq and having one thought about what
we were doing there and why and
you know what I later realized was was
uh you know a bag full of lies that was
sold to the American people that a lot
of us actually believed because we had
leaders in both parties who were telling
us hey this is true this is necessary
this is important for America it's
important for the world and then going
there in that situation and being
directly exposed to
um you know every day the
military-industrial complex you know
ever in our camp we had one of the big
we were one of the bigger camps in Iraq
and uh KBR Halliburton was the
contractor every single place in our
camp from the porta potties to the
little uh laundry Connex you know they
hired people from Nepal and the
Philippines to come and like hey you're
going to do laundry for the troops you
drop off your clothes they come back in
a plastic bag KBR Halliburton stamps on
everything on our food every single
thing that service that was provided in
our camp came through KBR Halliburton I
just talked to a friend of mine who is
on active duty is deployed to Poland
right now he said guess who is providing
all the services in our camp KBR
Halliburton we started making friends
with some of the people from the
Philippines who were there and like hey
how much are you getting paid how often
are you able to go home and visit your
family in the Philippines very very very
little pay knowing they're charging the
US government the military astronomical
amounts of money to to provide these
services so just one example of many of
the exploitation that occurs especially
during times of War but also during
times of peace from the
military-industrial complex who's making
all the money who is being exploited and
and at what cost so you know
experiencing that serving in a medical
unit where every day I was confronted
with the High human cost of War
though our brothers and sisters who who
paid the price either through injury or
making that ultimate sacrifice
these experiences hugely impacted me and
and caused me to go deeper to want to
learn more about the foreign policy
decisions that our country was making
learning more over time about the
unipart the unit party that is the war
machine in Washington and the forces
that be so that's one example of many
but but uh
you know I guess I guess intentionally
having the humility to understand and
know that I don't know everything and to
continue to learn whether it's on
foreign policy or domestic policy uh and
and keeping at the Forefront what's most
important is not me stand here and
saying I'm right at all what's most
important is is trying to find the right
answer in that mission of serving the
American people in the interests of our
country so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you